avec ledit confinement à les
consommateurs sont très heureux de
retrouver leurs habitudes dans les
restaurants et les commerces mais
plusieurs ont une surprise au moment de
passer à la caisse
puisque de nombreux établissements ont
ajouté des frais qu'au vu de leur
facture on va discuter de la légalité de
cette pratique avec charles tanguay
porte parole de l'office de la
protection du consommateur bonjour
monsieur tanguay bon on l'a vu la source
et de factures laissent que les
commerçants ont le droit d'imposer des
frais sont prises comme cela au bas de
la facture
le mot clé effectivement ses surprises
les commerçants sont libres de fixer les
prix qu'ils veulent et de facturer des
frais s'ils ont des vraies mais tout ça
doit se faire dans le respect de la loi
c'est-à-dire à un tube transparent
s'il ne faut pas que le consommateur
soit pris par surprise dans ces
l'article 224 c de la lpc qui s'applique
ici qui dit qu' aucun commerçant ne peut
exiger un prix supérieur au prix annoncé
donc pour un restaurant ça ferait partie
des annonces qui doivent être faites
s'il ya des frais par personne des frais
des frais d'entrée dans quelques
semaines ou des frais de table ça ne
doit pas arriver sur la facture après le
repas ça devrait être connu et déçu très
clairement par le client afin qu'ils
s'assoient à table c'est à dire donc
faudrait l'annoncé à la porte du
restaurant la limite la personne qui
vient vous placiez à votre table devrait
vous aviser qu'il y aura de ces frais là
pour que vous puissiez changer d'idée si
jamais ces frais là où déplaise et que
vous puissiez vous en aller
si vous ne voulez pas payer de tels
frais pendant mon essence je voyais
cette annulation le menu comme tel mais
donc vous dites ça même à l'entrée du
restaurant il faudrait que ce soit bien
indiqué basse tandis que sur le menu on
pourrait ne pas le voir il ya plusieurs
pages sur un menu on ne les consulte pas
décemment tout il faudrait vraiment que
la transparence soit au rendez vous
parce que effectivement on peut vous
attirer quelque part avec un faux brill
ce seul principe finalement de porcs à
être attirés en quelque part par des
prix qui ne ce qui ne reflète pas la
réalité on appelle aussi sa disposition
la salle du prix tout inclus alors un
commerçant pourrait tout simplement
augmenter le prix des repas à sur le
menu et ce serait évidemment tout à fait
acceptable
également mais si on a des frais
qu'ovide alors il faut qu'il soit
clairement annoncé mais avant qu'on
puisse se prendre la décision
même chose chez le coiffeur on ne peut
pas vous couper les cheveux et ensuite
vous dire qu'il y aura cinq de heures de
plus pour la coupe
alors que la coupe est en aussi à 20 $
plutôt dans l'établissement est ce qu'un
consommateur peut refuser de payer ces
frais là une fois qu'il reçoit la
facture
ça pourrait être une option temps de
dire je ne peux pas payer je les refuse
évidemment c'est sacré du chaos
une dispute vous pourriez aussi choisir
de payer puis après ça les contester ou
demander un remboursement en portant
plainte notamment à l'office de
protection du consommateur parce qu'on
aura ces commerçants l'a à l'oeil
j'ai l'impression que cette pratique là
ne se répandra pas très longtemps vu le
bruit que ça fait la mauvaise publicité
que ça peut faire
donc on comprend que les commerçants et
des frais supplémentaires
mais il faut pas qu'ils nous les fils en
douce et parfumée vous reçu des plaintes
à ce que je suis à ce sujet là on en a
probablement eu quelques-unes j'ai pas
encore pu faire le décompte est
effectivement des frais de toute nature
les gens se questionnent à tout le moins
sur leur légalité donc vous pouvez
effectivement appuyé le fils encore
doute faut préciser que les aliments
d'un autre professionnel ne sont pas
visés ne sont pas soumis à la loi sur la
protection du consommateur donc quand on
parle par exemple de psychologues ou on
en a parlé des dentistes aussi pour
référer à l'ordre professionnel en
question donc ce n'est pas le type de
plainte que vous pouvez recevoir de
consommateurs devraient s'adresser à
l'ordre des dentistes du québec pour des
frais de 25 dollars de plus ou encore
chez l'optométriste s'il y en avait
exact donc c'est bien des choses qu'il
faut bien retenir
est-ce que vous avez d'autres craintes
quant à des frais qu'andy le prétexte de
la conduite pourrait servir à augmenter
des frais qu'elle est que les
consommateurs devraient assumer
bon bah c'est sûr que en général il peut
y avoir une pression sur la haute cour à
la hausse pour les prix mais l'office ne
réglemente pas les prix bien sûr les
commerçants sont libres de fixer les
prix qu'ils veulent
il ya une disposition par contre qui
limite les a vus donc si
la hausse est tellement disproportionné
qu'elle constitue de l'exploitation du
consommateur à ce moment là un
consommateur pour incontesté des frais
exorbitants et donc encore une fois ci
si vous pensez subir des freins comme
cela qu'ils sont exorbitants vous
pourriez porter plainte à l'office et
vous renseigner de notre côté d'autres
conseils que vous pourriez donner aux
consommateurs quant à la vigilance
qu'ils devraient exercer lorsqu'elles
reçoivent une facture
bah il pourrait y avoir des frais
qu'ovide par la période des
déménagements donc ça sera surveillé là
on ignore quels seront les latitudes des
déménagements est certain que si on a
conclu une entente de tournage mans avec
un prix qui étaient déterminés à
l'avance il faudrait pour facturer des
frais qu'ovide qu'ils soient légaux il
faudrait qu'ils aient nouvelle entente
qui soit prise donc vous pourriez refusé
de payer des frais si le prix convenu ne
comprenait pas de frigo vide c'est bien
effectivement cette alerte pas en vue du
1er juillet merci d'avoir été avec nous
et tanguay au revoir